[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est l'événement sur Public
Sénat une édition spéciale que l'on vous
propose pour vivre en direct le vote du
texte immigration au Sénat à partir de
19h et puis à l'Assemblée
ensuite d'ailleurs notre décor et bleu
blanc rouge c'est vraiment le décor des
soirées événementielles sur sur
l'antenne et vous aurez alors jeis pas
habitué derrière moi c'est l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale donc ça va se
jouer là et je suis pas habitué ça va se
jouer là aussi évidemment beaucoup ce
soir beaucoup de questions puisque le
gouvernement et les LR sont parvenus à
un accord sur ce texte la CMP la
commission mixte paritaire et donc
conclusive c'est le terme qu'on qu'on
emploie mais à quel prix la majorité
présidentielle déjà fragile peut-elle
exploser ce soir les députés modem les
élus le de l'aile gauche de la macronie
vont-ils voter avec leur rassemblement
national et puis Emmanuel Macron qui a
promis vous le savez un rendez-vous à la
nation au mois de janvier peut-il ouvrir
pour pour de bon cette fois-ci un
nouveau chapitre de ce second quinena on
répondra à ces questions on a 1 heure
devant nous jusqu'au début du vote ici
au Sénat avec nos invités mais d'abord
ce que contient la loi immigration dans
sa toute dernière version avec Samia de
chir il aura fallu plus de 24 heures
pour y arriver la majorité
présidentielle et la droite ont
finalement trouvé un accord sur le
projet de loi immigration à la demande
de la droite les conditions de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier don les métiers en tenstion ont
été durcis ils devront entre autres
justifier d'un casier judiciaire vierge
é prouver leur respect des valeurs de la
République nous avons mis un échec un
texte qui était impuissant et inutile
voire qui avait des côtés dangereux sur
la régularisation des clandestins pour
promouvoir un texte responsable avec de
vraies dispositions qui sont de nature à
infléchir la politique migratoire autre
point d'accord sur les aides au logement
pour y avoir droit les étrangers qui
travaillent devront justifier de 3 mois
de présence en France et de 5 ans pour
ceux qui n'ont pas d'emploi une forme de
préférence nationale dénonce la gauche
qui accuse la droite et l'exécutif de
faire triompher le programme du
rassemblement national la CMP est
conclusive
est conclusive dans le déshonneur pour
la droite qui finalement a été l'idiot
utile du RN de fait le RN jubile Marine
Le Pen revendique une victoire
idéologique et appelle à voter cette
nouvelle version du projet de loi
immigration cette loi devient une loi de
durcissement des conditions de
l'immigration nous allons donc
voter cette ce texte tel qu'
ressort de la commission mixte paritaire
un soutien très embarrassant pour la
majorité
présidentielle plusieurs députés
macronistes de gauche ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils refuseraient de voter le texte au
côté du rassemblement national mais
l'exécutif ass sur pouvoir compter sur
les voies de la droite et du centre les
républicains la moitié du groupe Liot et
la majorité dans son ensemble qui est
donc favorable à l'accord puisque nous
avons réuni nos groupes et qu'il y a eu
des expressions donc on a pas besoin des
voix du rassemblement nationale la
nouvelle version du projet de loi
immigration sera examinée au Sénat
aujourd'hui à 19h puis à l'Assemblée
nationale à 21h et on va se compter au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
l'un des enjeux de cette soirée on vous
fait vivre en direct à la fois les
réactions des personnalités on sera euh
dans les différents lieux où où se joue
euh cette cette soirée tiens toute
dernière nouvelle on l'a pris il y a
quelques minutes Emmanuel Macron a
convoqué à 18h donc c'est en ce moment
euh une réunion avec sa majorité
parlementaire au sujet de ce projet de
loi je je je cite l'Agence France Presse
le président fait un point de situation
avec la première ministre les présidents
de groupe et les chefs de partis de la
majorité je vous présente tout de suite
euh mes invités Pascal Perino bonsoir
Pascal bienvenue politologue professeur
à scienceces PO Paris Émilie zapalski
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
communicante fondatrice de l'agence
Émilie conseil herwan lestran bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur conseil
à l'institut de sondage odxa lticia CR
éitorialist politique bonsoir laéticia
bienvenue à vous et puis en duplexe avec
nous de de la salle des conférences ici
au Sénat Quentin Calmet bonsoir Quentin
vous n'hésiterez pas évidemment à à à
nous faire signe dès que vous avez des
des invités et puis pour faire un un
point sur sur ce qui se joue on
reparlera peut-être de la forme Pascal
Perino mais sur le le fond sur le
contenu de la loi quelle leçon vous
tirez de cette commission mixte
paritaire écoutez comme la plupart du
temps la commission mixte paritaire a
fait son métier c'est-à-dire elle est
arrivée à un accord à concilier des avis
divergents dans la majorité des cas
lorsqu'il y a une commission mixte
paritaire ça débouche en effet sur un
compromis parce qu'on est dans un petit
cercle et c'est plus aisé de faire dans
l'intimité de la commission mixte
paritaire un accord que dans le le Chahu
mais sur le fond c'est un compromis ou
c'est un texte qui penseche clairement
vers ce que souhaitaent les LR et
notamment les sénateurs LR non pour les
c'est une victoire parce que ils ont
largement imposé toute une série de
thématiques visà-vis
desquels la majorité au début du
processus était réticente mais que
voulez-vous alors on est en France c'est
vrai je sais que le compromis c'est
quelque chose qui est très difficile à
imaginer pour les Français qui soit de
gauche de droite ou d'ailleurs dans un
compromis il faut un peu faire un bout
de chemin on n'est pas sur les mêmes
positions et là en effet Gérald man
avait essayé mais ça avait suscité des
hostilités du côté d'elr parce que
c'était un ancien LR et là on voit que
une fois géralde de daranin sorti du
champ et bien ils sont arrivés à une
situation de compromis dans lequel il y
a une victoire de LR et derrière en
effet un Ren qui une fois de plus se
réjouit en disant bah voilà toute une
partie de nos idées ont été reprises
mais attention c'est pas la première
fois que le vote à texte de la majorité
alors avec effectivement et on va on va
en parler des des risques de
fragmentation à court terme c'est sûr
mais peut-être aussi à moyen et plus
long terme de cette majorité
présidentielle Milie zapalski c'est vers
le Sénat je rappelle 19h ensuite
Assemblée nationale 21h30 ça c'est le
calendrier des votes ce soir est-ce que
vous diriez pour ellisabeth borne
sûrement mais peut-être aussi pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est une sorte d'heure
de vérité ce
soir une heure de vérité mais aussi
peut-être un éclaircissement sur
justement c'est en même temps qui
penchait de plus en plus à droite et là
qui clairement penche complètement à
droite avec même donc des idées reprises
ou en tout cas qui ressemblent beaucoup
au rassemblement national moi il me
semble que c'est un éclaircissement et
c'est assez intéressant parce que on
voit on a l'impression ça veut pas dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron d'un seul coup pr
Marine Le Pen politiquement que je dire
cont c'est une belle opé trve opération
de communication qu'il leur transmettent
au rassemblement national et on entend
depuis hier he presque mais surtout
depuis ce matin euh voilà ils ont choisi
la préférence nationale ce qui était
dans notre programme le rassemblement
national et ils se félicitent de tout ça
c'est un peu comme au rencontre de
Saint-Denis c'est s déroulé un tapis
rouge quand même une espèce d'opération
de communication très réussie pour le
rassemblement national alors qu'à la
base Emmanuel Macron et je reviens à son
élection était là justement pour faire
rempart au rassemblement national on a
entendu s r c'est le scénario qu'il
avait écrit pour gagner face à Marou
mais on a entendu on a entendu un Gérald
d'Anin récemment dimanche qui a dit si
on ne fait pas ça ce texte qui ressemble
beaucoup au RN c'est Marine Le Pen qui
est élu donc c'est une drôle de c'est un
drôle une drôle de façon d'éviter le RN
tout en utilisant les méthodes du
rassemblement national juste pour dire
ce qui est intéressant c'est que on a
l'impression que ça fait réapparaître le
clivage gauche- droite au au sein même
de la majorité puisque moi je pensais
pas qu'il qu'il y avait des rebelles
comme ça chaoulier qui qui annonce
qu'ils voteront contre le texte même si
probablement ça changera rien au vote
euh je pensais qu'ils allaient voilà
plutôt rentrer dans le et on a
l'impression que ça réveille les uns et
les autres même au-delà de la majorité à
gauche parce que quand même c'est un
texte qui qui qui fait un pas de plus
vis-à-vis des étrangers c'est un peu
particulier ouis on va détailler dans un
instant grâce à Quentin calmer un peu
l'état d'esprit des des
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle herwan lestran c'est
est-ce qu'elle peut imploser ce soir
cette majorité déjà fragile non
probablement pas mais en tout cas la
conclusion peut-être de ces derniers
jours c'est que l'immigration n'est pas
soluble dans le en même temps au même
titre que la sécurité c'est vrai qu'on
aurait pu l'observer mais ça ça ne
marche pas dans le en même temps vous le
disiez et c'est vrai ça réinstalle
complètement davantage marché hein non
plus mais mais on voit que le sur ces
sujets-là le clivage gauche-doite se
réinstalle complètement on l'a aussi sur
les questions de sécurité aujourd'hui
sur la stratégie la victoire va plutôt à
au Républicain sur l'idéologie plutôt
aun mais mais en tout cas le l'enjeu
pour la majorité aujourd'hui c'est
probablement soit de rester uni soit de
limiter l'existence de frondeur en
interne on av vu comme ils avaient sapé
le quinquena de de François Hollande
c'est ce serait bien pour Emmanuel
Macron de minimiser le poids des
frondeurs dans son mouvement après un an
de mandat oui et puis signe de ses
tension je vous le rappelle réunion de
la majorité en ce moment même à l'Élysée
au tour du président de la République
Quentin calm vous êtes donc en en salle
des conférences ici au au Sénat vous
vous avez vous suivez hein cette
commission mixte paritaire depuis hier
pour pour Public Sénat dans dans quel
vous avez peu dormi hein merci de de de
tenir la baraque comme ça voilà c'est
aussi ça le métier de journaliste dans
quel estat d'esprit sont les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle que vous avez croisé ces
dernières heures effectivement Thomas on
était aux quatre colonnes à l'Assemblée
nationale on a retrouvé le décor
traditionnel le public sén la salle des
conférences effectivement ces dorur et
la moquette rouge effectivement auquel
on est habitué mais effectivement à la
Assemblée nationale on a vu dès 40
minutes avant la fumée blanche et
l'accord de la Commission mixte
paritaire des députés renaissan assez
mal à l'aise quand les journalistes leur
posaient des questions en salle des
quatre colonnes et parce que par exemple
Sylvain Maillard le chef de fil des
députés de renaissance il est passé
assez blême on peut le dire en disant
juste un laconique il va manquer
quelques voix à la majorité et là
effectivement depuis l'annonce de
l'accord de la CMP 17h30 on voit des
députés modemes ù Renaissance donner
leur position à titre personnel comme et
bien Jean-Paul Matei le président du
groupe modem qui pourrait emporter avec
lui plusieurs députés modem et qui a
annoncé qu'il allait voter contre
l'accord de la CMP même même chose pour
Sacha aoulier un personnage emblématique
le président de la commission des lois
de l'Assemblée nationale il est
Renaissance c'est lui qui dirigeait les
travaux de la CMP il a annoncé qu'il
allait voter contre un autre député
Renaissance appelé ses collègue
Renaissance qui hésitait et bien à cause
de la rédaction trop à droite de
l'accord de la CMP il les appelait à
s'abstenir plutôt qui a voté contre lors
de nos échanges en salle des quatre
colonnes tout à l'heure Renaissance qui
espère ainsi profiter des 62 voix DLR
grâce à l'abstention de à cause de
l'abstention de certains de leurs
collègues Renaissance quant au fait que
le rassemblement national appelle à
voter le texte ces députés Renaissance
ils étaient clairement gênés ils nous
ont dit on na jamais compter sur les
voies du rassemblement national ils font
aujourd'hui un coup politique une
manière de se rassurer avec nous même
s'ils étaient effectivement très
embarrassé devant la presse Thomas merci
Quentin encore une fois n'hésitez pas si
vous avez des des invités à faire
intervenir en direct ou pour nous livrer
d'autres information à nous faire signe
autre information livrée par nos
confrères de l'Agence France Presse avec
cette expression baiser de la mort
employé par un député renaissance
macroniste de la première heure pour
qualifier finalement ce choix du
rassemblement nation de voter le texte
et d'obliger les députés en naissance
modem à se positionner l'une des
premières d'ailleurs à avoir pris la
parole après le l'annonce d'e de cette
commission mixte paritaire conclusive
c'est Marine Le Pen qui annonce que donc
le le vote du parti on l'a entendu déjà
dans le sujet de Samia Deir alors je
vous propose de remonter quelques heures
plus tôt Jordan Bardella qui parlait
déjà de victoire idéologique écoutons la
victoire idéologique du rassemblement
national est de plus en plus forte
chaque jour on est passé d'un texte que
nous avons mis en échec à l'Assemblée
nationale qui
prévoyait des mesures d'accélération de
l'immigration avec cette cette ouverture
d'une nouvelle filière d'immigration via
la régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier qui constitue en soi une prime à
l'illégalité un texte durci sur les
conditions d'octroi des aides sociales
notamment aux étrangers sur le
rétablissement du délit de séjour
irrégulier mon analyse c'est qu'on a là
la conséquence concrète du rassemblement
national à 30 % dans les sondages et
donc dans quelques heures la loi va
peut-être passer à
l'Assemblée Pascal Perino grâce aux voix
du rassemblement national c'est c'est
quand même un affront pour c'est pas
évident qu'ils aient besoin des voix du
du rassemblement national le
rassemblement national votera parce que
il va pas se priver de ce
plaisir mais voilà il pourra y avoir une
majorité sans forcément l'apport des
députés des députés du Front national
mais surtout là on est tout au délices
des prises de position des des partis
des députés des sénateurs et cetera mais
enfin euh une majorité elle doit
représenter la majorité du pays or que
constate-t-on depuis des semaines et des
semaines l'Institut odoxal l'a fait euh
d'autres institut comme laab l'ont fait
ils ont pris toutes les mesures dans du
du projet de loi et ils ont demandé aux
Français ce qu'ils en pensaient sur
toutes les mesures à peu près sans
aucune exception les Français à des
majorités fortes sont d' avec
uncissement ou qu'il faut appeler un
durcissement des conditions ils étaiit
aussi d'accord avec l'article 3 si je
symp donc l'équilibre plaisait aussi au
français non mais enfit globalement si
vous voulez les Français il y a plus de
à peu près de tiers des Français qui
disent qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en
France voyez on voit bien qu'il y a une
droitisation sur ce thème qui est une
droitisation sensible qui touche pas
simplement l'électorat de la droite
l'électorat du rassemblement national
mais aussi l'électorat de la majorité et
l'électorat de la gauche jusqu'aux
électorats et les filles 40 % des
électeurs des sympathisants desfi disent
qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en France
voyez donc quand on parle de la
représentation estce c'est une victoire
idéologique du rassemblement national
pour reprendre les mots de Jordan
Bardella oui parce que certaines mesures
sont des mesures qui sont des mesures
que le rassemblement national préconise
depuis longtemps mais il y a d'autres
mesures que LR préconisaitou que le
modem avait pu préconiser que
Renaissance avait préconisé d'acc émil
qui voulez intervenir il il y a ces mots
qui qui sont employés notamment par la
gauche pour
finalement qualifier ce qui s'est passé
au sein de cette commission mixte
paritaire qui reviennne sur les mots
préférence nationale est-ce que cette
loi dans sa dernière version est
imprégnée finalement de la préférence
nationale telle qu'elle est pensé par le
rassemblement national ou le Front
national auparavant en tout c'est comme
ça que le Rassemblement National veut
marquer cette loi on entend ici est-ce
qu'on tombe pas dans le piège du Aren
quand finalement on reprend cette
rétorique c'est ce qu'a dit Gérald Harin
en disant attention c'est déjà ce qui
est le cas pour le RSA par exemple que
les étrangers ne le touchent pas tout de
suite qu'il faut un délai de 5 ans donc
ça existe déjà mais quand même c'est des
pas supplémentairire moi je reviens
juste sur cette droitisation de la
population française il faut regarder
quand même dans la nuance tout ce qui
est dit oui il demande plus de fermeté
et on peut le comprendre avec tout ce
qu'on vit notamment en terme de
terrorisme de qtf de obligation quit le
territoire français qui sont pas
respectés pas appliqué je suis pas sûr
que la loi va permettre plus
d'application de ce côté-là parce que ça
dépend pas de nous ça dépend de
l'international donc les Français oui
demandent plus de fermeté mais comme
vous l'avez dit ils étaient aussi
d'accord sur cet article 3 de
régularisation des 100 papiier pour des
métiers en tension ce qui a été
fortement durci dans une version les
républicains où il y a plein de
contraintes particulière l'article enfin
le le la mesure reste mais dans une
version d'ailleurs qui va que jusqu'à
fin 2026 si j'en crois ce qui ressort du
texte qui sera établi de la CMP enfin du
texte de la CMP donc quelque chose qui
est un petit peu rabougerri par rapport
donc je suis pas sûr que les Français
oui ils ont cette envie et quand on les
questionne ils ont envie de plus de
fermeté mais ils ont aussi cette
ouverture qui est un peu la philosophie
de la France d'accueil de régularisation
de personnes qui en plus nous servent
parce que c'est des métiers qu'on fera
pas donc je pense que c'est un petit peu
plus nuancé moi ce que je trouve c'est
que là le texte oui ouvertement il passe
un cran DESS et puis surtout il a libéré
beaucoup de paroles très décomplexées et
c'est là je trouve que c'est grave ça
fait un an et demi he que Gérald
harmanin se traîné ce projet de loi qui
a eu des discussions est-ce qu'on le
fait en saucisson pour faire passer à
gauche à droite parce qu'on voit bien le
mal qu'ils ont eu pour le faire passer
si si si ils arrivent au bout pendant
tout ce temps-là oui les paroles ont été
très décomplexées et on sait qu'on
entend souvent plutôt ceux qui cri fort
et ceux qui sont radicaux dans tout ça
et ça crée dans la société il me semble
une parole très décomplexée mais ça veut
pas dire que c'est le reflet de tout ce
que pensent les Français on va voir et
on voit déjà la dans la majorité que ça
grince des dents justement par ce côté
jusqu'au bouhiste un petit peu des
mesures un petit peu plus fermes on va
voir si dans la société française on a
vu déjà des manifestations contre ce
texte arriver on va voir comment ça se
passe Herman ces termes préféren
nationales ils sont clairement associés
au au Front national d'abord enfin au Le
Pen père père et fille pour oui tout à
fait tout à fait même au FN plutôt qu'
j'all dire mais en tout cas c'est c'est
de la préférence pour la présence sur le
territoire national aujourd'hui plutôt
que de la préférence nationale mais
c'est vrai que ça y ressemble mais et je
rebondis sur ce que disait Pascal Perino
il y a un contexte d'opinion que les
députés les sénateurs ne doivent pas
ignorer on a 6 Français sur 10
aujourd'hui qui considèrent qu'on évolue
vers trop d'assistana qui considère
qu'il y a trop d'étrangers en France on
voit le soutien au droit d'asile qui a
tendance à reculer dans la population on
a 7 Français sur 10 qui juge que la
politique en matière d'immigration est
trop laxiste donc voir des Français qui
préfèrent un projet privilégiant un
contrôle durci de l'immigration plutôt
qu'améliorer l'intégration des étranger
c'est assez logique dans le contexte
actuel la semaine dernière on
interrogait les Français au sortir du
vote de la motion de rejet il y en a
uniquement 3/ 10 qui souhaitit un
abandon du projet et parmi les 7/10 qui
voulaient un projet il voulait
majoritairement un projet qui penche à
droite proche de celui des des sénateurs
donc ça va plutôt dans le sens des
Français et c'est vrai que il y a
peut-être un risque pour les par ire
apparaître hors sol par rapport à ses
préoccupations dans un contexte qui plus
est d'actualité qui fait remonter les
préoccupations sur la sécurité et sur
l'immigration qui sont revenu à haut
niveau dans la population qui sont des
thématiques l'immigration et la sécurité
très sensible à l'aualité il semble
quand même que on rédu le chant
d'analyse pardon je sais que c'est
efficace à des moments au sondage il
faut regarder où ont voté les Français
on n'arrête pas de dire la France é
droit depuis 2022 il faut regarder les
élections on est encore en démocratie
représentative pour l'instant
excusez-moi c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
est passé valc je vous rappelle la
candidate de la droite moins de 5 % 62
député h la France à l'heure où on se
parle n'est pas à droite donc on verra
2027 en fait c'est c'est ça qui a qui
est un petit peu particulier soit le
gouvernement finalement voulait un texte
plus dur soit il a flanché pour
justement un parti qui a pesé en 2022
moins de 5 % Paris que finalement c'est
ça qui c'est ça qui est difficile à
comprendre il y a il y a une logique
parlementaire qui qui est l'incapacité à
faire passer des des des textes même
s'il y a beaucoup de lois qui ont été
votées parfois avec des député de gauche
qui les votait parfois avec desputé de
droite mais dès qu'un texte on l'a déjà
dit ici prend toute la lumière
médiatique là ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué de trouver une majorité on VO
terrible parce que le la réforme des
retraites les Français y étaient
majoritairement opposés on a eu le 493
pour le faire passer là vous le dites
dans les sondages les Français étaient
majoritairement pour un un texte plus
ferme et et on en arrive au bout du bout
avoir la copie DLR enfin le gouvernement
aurait pu peut-être aller jusqu'à ça et
peut-être même imposer un 493 puisque ça
allait dans le sens des Français vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que là
on a l'impression qu'ils ont pris la
copie des républicains qui ne pesaent en
effet en 2022 pas grand-chose alors que
ça va dans le sens des Français c'est
pas très cohérent ou on est en
démocratie représentative les républains
expliquer pourquoi il y a cette
droitisation alors que c'était pas
l'objet du texte pas tous en même temps
si si moi je je rajoute les TR à parler
en même temps personne nend Ren
expliquer au français aux électeurs mais
au français comment LR a pesé autant
dans la balance alors que je vous
rappelle que c'était moins de 5 % mais
oui mais c'est c'est aussi une majorité
avec avec les centristes i au Sénat on
va pas oui mais ça c'est réel ça c'est
la majorité ici au Sénat elle pèse aussi
voilà je voudrais je vous donne la
parole tout de suite Pascal Perino qu'on
qu'on entende justement puisqueil y a
cette critique voir cette accusation
d'un
amalgame du gouvernement avec l'extrême
droite la première ministre cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée a répondu elle
s défenduabeth borne sortez des slogans
des postures en voulant faire croire en
voulant faire l'amalgame entre notre
texte et les positions de l'extrême
droite les mots les mots ont un sens
monsieur les mots ont un sens monsieur
le Président chassigne l'extrême droite
c'est le rejet des étrangers par
principe parce qu'ils sont étrangers
l'extrême droite c'est la préférence
nationale nous nous croyons à
l'intégration par le
nous nous
voulons nous nous voulons continuer à
former des talents et à diffuser notre
culture en accueillant des étudiants
internationaux l'extrême
droite l'extrême droite l'extrême droite
c'est le refus d'accueillir même ceux
qui sont en danger le droit d'asile
c'est au cœur de nos valeurs monsieur le
Président chass not elle répondait au
président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée André chassigne Pascal Pino
est-ce voilà est-ce qu'elle a finalement
raison de faire la différence de dire
cette loi telle qu'elle ressort de la
commission mixte paritaire c'est une loi
effectivement LR mais pas RN non c'est
pas une loi Ren par exemple on parle de
la préférence nationale la préférence
nationale c'est
d'exclure d'exclure selon le critère de
la nationalité euh les étrangers de
l'accès à telle ou telle aide là ça
n'est pas le cas dans la loi on durcit
les conditions d'accès en terme de durée
sur le territoire national et cetera on
les durcit on n'est pas dans de la
préférence nationale à l'état pur hein
ce qui a toujours été le projet du Front
national puis du rassemblement euh
national donc ça n'est pas le projet du
RN mais le RN avait dit d'ailleurs
auparavant si ça va dans le bon sens euh
nous accompagnerons le sens et en plus
de ça on s'imera le trouble et regardez
ce on est en plein danse ça y est on est
en plein de D et comme toujours à chaque
fois qu'il y a cette question du RN les
grands mots sortent les postures le camp
du Bien et le camp du mal et cetera et
on ne parle plus tellement du sujet
pardon c'est daté ah oui oui oui oui
ouié oui bien sûr parce que tout de même
depuis juin 2022 il y a une vraie
majorité relative mais qui est au fond
presque une grosse minorité hein et il
faut bien aller chercher les voies donc
construire sans cesse des compromis sur
le social plutôt avec la gauche sur le
régalien on le voit plutôt avec la
droite jusqu'au rassemblement
national c'est intéressant par on est
dans la normalisation souhaitée par le
bien sûr surtout qu'aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas que la première force
politique en France c'est le
rassemblement national il suffit de
regarder les enquêtes tous les jours oui
on regardera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
l'enquête que doxa et mascar ont fait
pour pour pour Public Sénat et la presse
quotidienne régionale sur des des
projections de de vote si on votait
dimanche aux européennes on on vous
donnera ça tout à
l'heure quand vous entendez Pascal
Perino finalement nous donner ses
arguments ça vous fait ça vous fait
tiquer mais bon voilà il y a une
normalisation on peut la regretter on
doit l'accepter comment vous leagiss ça
je crois que c'est plus qu'une
normalisation là qu'on est en train de
de de faire pour le rassemblement
national c'est vraiment une rampe de
lancement terrible est-ce que non mais
attendez on po toujours notre
responsabilité mais il y a il y a il y a
des Français qui votent il y a des
enquêes comprend bien il y a il y a le
compromis de l'Assemblée et du Sénat
avec cette CMP si on revient au discours
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2022 quand il a
gagné il a dit j'ai bien compris que on
m'a élu aussi pour éviter Marine Le Pen
et que ce vote m'oblige mais il oblige
en quoi en rien du tout c'est-à-dire que
là on se dit bah finalement j'aurais
mieux fait de voter rassemblement
national parce que justement c'est le
parti qui peut aller encore plus loin
sur cette fermeté parce que on va pas
s'arrêter à 3 mois pour les allocations
de logement par exemple on va aller
jusqu'à 5 ans ou on va aller jusqu'à bah
si c'est des étrangers ils auront pas du
tout de logement en fait il y a une
espèce de R de lancement qui est
terriblement faite là avec cette façon
de de se mettre à genou par rapport à
des mesures c'est un début c'est un
début c'est un
débutarum pardon n interrompe l'argument
que vous nous donnez Émilie c'est
exactement celui d'Olivier fort le le
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
qui parle de trahison on l'écoute c'est
une trahison une trahison pour toutes
celles et ceux qui ont fait le choix
précisément de de faire barrage à
l'extrême droite en votant Emmanuel
Macron et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est très dangereux aussi parce que
quel est celui ou celle qui acceptera
encore de faire barrage demain si
l'utualité se présentait avec un
macroniste plus personne ne peut y
croire plus personne ne peut accepter
l'idée que on fait barrage à l'extrême
droite avec le vote Renaissance ou le
vote Macron ça n'est plus possible parce
qu'ils appliquent eux-mêmes la politique
de mari Le Pen et je la vois se
féliciter se délecter de ce moment où au
fond les combats de son père sont en
train d'être en fait à la fois mis en
valeur et achevé par Emmanuel Macron
lui-même lui qui avait été élu
précisément pour faire barrage à ces
idéesl c'est un
scandalerand est-ce qu'on peut analyser
ça comme ça c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
vient de trahir les électeurs de gauche
qui avaient voté pour lui en en 2022
alors peut-être ce qui avent voté
surtout pour lui en en 2017 je pense que
justement dans dans le vote de ce soir
ce sera intéressant de de regarder parmi
les députés qui le vote des députés
selon que ce sont des députés qui
viennent de la législature 2017 ou 2022
où sa base électorale était déjà un peu
plus à droite pour Emmanuel Macron le
fait qu'il fasse des majorités de
compromis c'est relativement attendu par
les Français ils sont d'ailleurs même
très en attente du fait que l'ensemble
des sensibilités de l'Assemblée
nationale soit soit prise en compte en
revanche si c'était systématiquement des
majorités pour ch à droite là ce ne
serait plus le président du en même
temps qui pour la première fois on a été
victime parce que c'est vrai que en même
temps s'est retourné contre lui avec les
les majorités et de gauche et de droite
qui qui vote la motion de de rejet pour
l'instant ça n'apparaîtrait pas
forcément une traitise surtout si la
majorité est atteinte sans le vote des
députés rassemblement national mais ça
peut être une brique fondatrice du
sentiment d'ingouvernabilité
d'incapacité à construire des majorités
deux présidents penchant définitivement
à droite ça peut être les les prémisses
d'une de qu chose qui va fragmenter mais
moi j'ai une petite question
arithmétique pour bien alors je vais
vous interrompre pardon vous la poserez
juste après puisque Quentin calm
surveiller ça sur nos écran de contrôle
est avec Bruno rotaillot le président du
groupe LR ici au Sénat Quentin c'est à
vous oui effectivement Thomas merci
Bruno rotao de venir au micro de public
c'est pour cette première réaction
depuis lacord rrouvé en commission mixte
paritaire qu'est-ce que vous dites sur
ce qui ressort de cette réunion de la
CMP c'est un texte qui vous convient car
proche de celui du Sénat ça ne pouvait
pas être autrement je veux pas avoir le
triomphe modeste mais très franchement
il y avait un seul texte le seul texte
qui avait été voté par une des deux
assemblées du Parlement français c'est
le texte du Sénat donc ça ne pouvait
être que un texte tout proche et on a eu
de belles victoires mais la victoire
c'est je pense pour les Français près de
80 % des Français nous demandent de la
fermeté 80 % pensent qu'il y a trop
d'immigration en France et par rapport
au passé ce qui est intéressant à noter
c'est que ce sont des Français de droite
mais aussi de gauche donc c'est un très
large consensus alors que vous savez que
nous sommes un peuple un peu Gaulois
querelleur et que nous sommes souvent
très fracturés et bien sur cette
question migratoire les Français ont
cette conscience que désormais il faut
mettre fin au désordre migratoire une
réaction au fait que Marine Le Pen
appelle à voter le texte qui ressort de
la CMP on peut se réjouir d'une victoire
idéologique dit la présidente du groupe
RN à l'Assemblée nationale elle vous
tire un peu la victoire elle aussi non
elle veut voler la victoire mais la
vérité elle est très simple c'est que
d'ailleurs dès la lecture au Sénat les
représentants les représentants du
rassemblement national se sonent opposés
voilà et ce que je veux dire c'est que
nous portons ici au Sénat depuis des
années et des années un certain nombre
de convictions qu'on a exprimé dans des
rapports avec François Noël buffet nous
les avons exprimé par exemple sur la
manifestation de la volonté c'était un
dispositif pasqui voyz que monsieur
bardellaa était même pas en culotte
courte donc arrêtons le scandale elle se
réj du fait que la priorité nationale
rentre dans la loi et que ça c'est une
victoire idéologique pour le RN la
priorité nationale au sens de Madame Le
Pen c'était de réserver par exemple les
allocations familiales exclusivement aux
Français nous on a un temps de carence
tout simplement parce qu'on considère
que lorsqu'on entre sur le territoire
national dans la communauté nationale et
bien il y a un équilibre entre des
devoirs et de droits les Français en ont
marre de payer de plus en plus souvent
pour des services publics qui sont de
moins en moins performants et je pense
qu'il faut avoir une différence c'est
c'est naturel c'est la différence euh
qui est une différence fondamentale
entre des citoyens nationaux et des gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur j'ai une
dernière question sur le fond du texte
vous ne vouliez pas de régularisation
dans ce projet de loi il y aura bien un
article 4 bis avec des régularisations
au cas par cas vous avez dû concéder
cela vous le reconnaissez vous voulez
rire non mais vous voulez rire toujours
pas compris ce'était l'article 4 bis non
il y avait un article 3 c'était un
droitou tout c'était un droit opposable
on a supprimé l'article 3 à partir du
moment où il y avait plus d'article 3 il
y avait la circulaire Vals et bien nous
on a renforcé la circulaire Vals on l'a
renforcé dans son champ d'application
c'est seulement les métiers au tenstion
on l'a renforcé dans son contrôle
désormais avec le mode de vie avec
l'ordre public avec les principes de la
République ça cas Judici je sais ça la
voyez voyez toutes les différences par
rapport à la circulaire Vals très bien
c'est du beau travail ça non et ben
merci pour cette réaction en direct au
micro de public sonab brun merci à vous
merci à tous les deux merci Quentin et
n'hésitez pas évidemment à nous faire
signe avec d'autres invités ou avec
d'autres informations euh Pascal Perino
euh on peut dire ce soir que c'est une
revanche deslr on peut aller jusque là
oui d'une certaine manière parce qu'ils
avaient bien du mal à exister plus à
l'Assemblée nationale d'ailleurs qu'au
Sénat parce que ce qui est important
c'est vrai dans ce que dit le président
du groupe parlementaire au Sénat
DLR le projet qui a été voté mais c'est
un projet qui a été voté dans une
assemblée dans lequelle il y a pour
ainsi dire absolument pas le
rassemblement national à savoir le Sénat
c'est un
projet s donc il faut voyez un peu
modérer cette impression qui consiste à
dire c'est une victoire du rassemblement
national et cetera au fond il continue
un combat qu'il mène d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs années hein alors ensuite on
peut dire il y a une influence
idéologique beaucoup plus large la
fameuse leupénisation des esprits mais
ça j'allais dire ça date ça date et ça
touche pas simplement des députés ou des
sénateurs ça touche les Français
simplement hein donc oui les LR arrivve
là à se refaire une santé d'abord ils
sont unis entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale ça c'est c'est très important
parce qu'on avait de plus en plus de LR
peut-être trois d'ailleurs il y avait le
parti il y avait celui du Sénat puis il
y avait celui de l'Assemblée nationale
ça faisitant il leur faudra trouver un
candidat pour 202 oui mais ça bon ils
ont le temps hein ils ont le temps ils
ont trouvé déjà un candidat apparemment
pour pour les européennes bon chaque
chose en son temps parce pour l'instant
personne n'a à peu près de candidats
pour la prochaine présid rapidement sur
les LR il y encore beaucoup juste sur
les LR je pense que la séquence elle va
elle sera pas très durable elle va être
courte cette séquence parce que oui il
se cramponne sur ce sujet de
l'immigration il court derrière les
idées du rassemblement national parce
que c'est leur identité et que
globalement ils n'ont pas développé
depuis le temps beaucoup d'autres idées
qui les différencieraient forcément des
macronistes donc si on tire un petit peu
plus sur la droite et du rassemblement
national ils sont sur l'immigration h
pas compris rembl nation il a ouvert les
Van les thémaes et on l'a bien vu avec
une Marine Le Pen qui en 2022 a parler
surtout du pouvoir d'achat donc quelque
part le rassemblement national sera
toujours plus fort sur ses fondamentaux
et il a même plus besoin d'en rajouter
10000 couches donc je pense que cette
cette victoire évidemment c'est normal
qu'il s'en félicit et qu'ils en fassent
beaucoup mais ça sera pas durable
peut-être y a quand même un message
d'efficacité lancé par le parti à ses
électeurs ce soir de savoir faire
politique tout à fait absol le texte
c'est le nôtre et c'est celui alors on
va voir s'il passe ou pas dans quelques
he mais c'est celui qui mais la
démonstration voilà d'un certain
savoir-faire politique mais je je
rebontis ce qui a été sur ce qui a été
dit qui est intéressant c'est que sur
les préoccupations des électeurs les
deux principales préoccupations des
électeurs LR c'est la sécurité et
l'immigration mais les deux principales
préoccupations des sympathisants Ren
c'est l'immigration et le pouvoir
d'achat donc finalement sur ce couple
sécurité immigration est quand même près
des prérogatives LR enfin en tout cas
des des grosses préoccupations de leur
leurs électeurs donc ça va bien dans
leur sens et c'est vrai que cet accord
avec une passerelle intelligente entre
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale c'est
la démonstration d'un savoir faire
politique Laeticia on on arrive à quoi
40 jours je crois de tractation
parlementaire autour de ce texte ce qui
va rester selon vous c'est un spectacle
politique déplorable dont la démocratie
est la grande perdante expliquez-nous
pourquoi vous dites ça écoutez je crains
je je sais qu'ici on a on a l'analyse et
que on la met vraiment voilà au début de
toutes les discussions je crains que les
Français ne retiennent pas les points
sur lesquels la commission mix paritaire
s'est déchiré par exemple les grands
points de cette loi immigration je pense
que ce qui va rester c'est ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure Bruno retaillot sous les
flash voilà en fait il faut se regarder
où sont les projecteurs aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qui intéresse les Français qui
est sur la scène qui est sur le devant
de la scène ensuite les idées viendront
bien sûr les idées arrivent toujours
mais pour le moment effectivement je
crois que le spectacle déplorable que
donnent les politiques grâce au médias
va détruire les bases de notre
démocratie
représentative le problème c'est que
tout le monde se se jette la balle de la
responsabilité bah oui depuis on
commence à en avoir l'habitude les
Français aussi depuis le feuilleton des
retraites au an dernier là maintenant
c'est la tragédie de la loi immigration
où les les oppositions
F en tête disent par exemple là pour
l'immigration vous savez on on entend à
nouveau la petite musique du dénis de
démocratie alors les uns accusent les
autres le la l'opposition accuse la
majorité d'un dénis de démocratie de
cette faite complètement à la main de LR
ce petit parti qui finalement comme je
disais tout à l'heure n'a pas beaucoup
de justification et alors de son côté la
majorité
accuse les minorités qui ont empêché le
débat parlementaire tout simplement
comme l'a fait Françis Baayou qui est
proche d'Emmanuel Macron sur RTL
dimanche il a dit que les députés qui
avaient refusé le débat finalement
n'auraient pas la mission que les
Français leur avaient donné en refusant
de travailler c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
été élus et ils refusent leur mission
ils refusent de débattre ils refusent de
voter les lois François baayrou qui
selon nos confrères de de l'Agence
France Presse alors c'est plusieurs des
sources concordantes comme on dit qui
qui le cite François n'accepte pas un
texte revendiqué par le rassemblement
national voilà le président du MoDem on
verra bien comment vote les députés
modem tout à l'heure et la presse dans
tout ça Léticia et bien les médias on on
en a l'illustration ce soir profite de
ce Koo ubuesque hein pour comme on dit
dans le jargon feuilletonner vous savez
on crée un feuilleton donc on attend
tous le prochain épisode qu'est-ce qui
va se passer et alors on a même pas
besoin d'allumer la télé on a tous sur
nos téléphonees portaable ça tombe comme
ça minut minut après minute à un tel
accuse un tel qui accuse un tel et alors
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu le
journal l'opinion a résumé la
problématique dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui à sa Une aujourd'hui il dit
la démocratie à H clos pourquoi parce
que les journalistes vont encore plus
loin ils disent que finalement la loi
immigration ne va pas sortir de la CMP
mais des dîners à H clos qui se sont
organisés autour d'éisabeth borne comme
celui d'hier soir par exemple où elle av
de ministres général d'armanin Fran
rester et quatre représentants DLR à
Matignon elle les a multiplié hein ses
dînés ellisabeth un autre exemple c'est
le coup de téléphone du président de la
République coup de téléphone à Elizabeth
borne et à Bruno rotillot qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure alors qu'il recevait les
handballeuses françaises victorieux
victorieus championne du monde et alors
ça ça a fait aussi sur nos téléphones on
a tous reçu le pouche de notification
alors on sait qui a appelé qui qui a
reçu qui a dîné normalement C
informations sont censé rester privé ah
oui mais c'est le rôle des journalistes
de les faire sortir aussi d'ailleurs
brunoou a démenti ce ce coup de fil
présiden et l'Élysée également et alors
les journalers ont ce rôle là mais aussi
les politiques c'est-à-dire que les
politiques font fuiter ces informations
et les médias les reprennent et donc
vous nous dites quoi que ça réduit la
démocratie à ces à ces coups de
téléphone oui au final on a l'impression
que la loi immigration s'est joué à
hclos c'est vrai dans le huclos du
pouvoir et et c'est vrai que on a
l'impression d'être d'avoir regardé ce
ce feuilleton de la loi immigration dans
nos dans nos canapés paisiblement mais
comme on regarderait Dallas ou amour
gloire et beauté amour gloire et beauté
j'ésite entre les deux mais ceux qui ont
la référence chois son V des références
qui commencent à dater un petit peu on
n'est pas tous forcément d'accord mais
mais je trouve que c'est intéressant
pour lancer cette partie du du débat
autour de de de ce thème
d'affaiblissement de la démocratie on
peut aussi considérer je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez Pascal Perino tient
peut-être que bon ben on a une CMP qui a
fonctionné des des des des sénateurs des
députés qui ont discuté même si
effectivement bon on a eu un peu
l'impression que le centre de gravité se
décalait vers vers vers matigon alors je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
François
patria le le président du groupe
Renaissance je simplifie ici au Sénat
est avec Quentin calm
quentincord trouvé entre député et
sénateur en commission mixte paritaire
c'est un bon accord qui a été trouvé
écoutez je pense que cet accord nous
l'avons travaillé avec le gouvernement
avec Madame borne à plusieurs reprises à
matigan le gouvernement avait fixé ses
propres lignes rouges qui concernent sur
trois points à l'origine en fin de
compte les choses ont évolué sur H
points et non des moindres sur le code
de la nationalité sur l'ame sur la
rédaction de l'article 4 bis sur le
logement d'urgence sur les étudiants sur
les les allocations familiales le reste
les choses ont évolué dans le sens où
nous le souhaitions à partir du moment
où nous sommes majoritaires et qu' part
du texte du Sénat bien entendu c'est pas
seulement un compromis c'est un accord
qui a été je crois accepté y compris par
le président de la commission mix
paritaire ce matin donc que dit ça je
vous interromps mais Sacha aoulier vient
d'annoncer que à titre personnel il
allait voter contre l'accord trouvé en
CMP tout comme Monsieur mati le chef de
fil des députés modem les
multiplications comme ça de réaction de
députés qui à titre personnel annonce
qu'ils ne vont pas voter ou voter contre
l'accord de la CMP que ça vous évoque je
crois d'abord qu'il faut reprendre un
peu de calme et un peu de de hauteur en
l'occurrence et on verra bien ce qui se
passera ce soir j'ai compris que les
chefs de la majorité de l'Assemblée
nationale sont à l'heure actuelle anéisé
ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui c'est
que le président de la commission des
lois et de la commission mix paritaire a
voté l'accord il a accepté l'accord en
commission il a accepté la Commission et
pourquoi veut-il changer d'avis
maintenant parce que parce que le groupe
LR aujourd'hui change son vote mais je
crois qu'il faut évacuer la position des
LR elle ne nous concerne pas elle ne
nous intéresse pas le LR qui voulait
voter contre
hier veut voter pour aujourd'hui c'est
un vote tactique politique que nous
devons ignorer aujourd'hui nous devons
nous concentrer sur l'accord qui a été
élaboré avec les républicains et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui donc le vote
des des des RN vous voulez dire ou le
vote DLR le vote des le vote des RN
pardon le vote des RN n concerne pas
voilà ok donc ça ne ça ne vous dérange
pas que à la fin le texte convienne au
rassemblement national ça dit pas
quelque chose ça c'est un vote tactique
nous ne votons pas aujourd'hui avec le
RN le RN fait ce qu'il veut à côté si à
chaque fois que le RN changer de vote
nous devions changer notre vote
nous-même pas du tout on ne doit pas
tenir compte aujourd'hui du vote RN pour
nous déterminer on doit tenir compte de
l'accord qui a été construit patiemment
avec le gouvernement et la majorité et
la majorité du Sénat cet accord la CMP
l'a validé les réactions maintenant en
fonction du vote du RN je crois
aujourd'hui doivent être prises avec
beaucoup de de hauteeur sans détourner
aujourd'hui et voter le texte qui a été
const monsieur patri une dernière
question vous reconnaissez quand même
une crise au sein de la majorité pour
qu'on en vienne à une réunion à l'Élysée
avec les ministres concernés les cadres
de renaissance et les autres partis de
la majorité c'est bien qu'il y a une
crise j'ai bien le sentiment qu'il y a
une partie de la majorité qui
aujourd'hui se sent mal à l'aise avec
elle aurait voulu le texte de de
l'Assemblée mais quand on n'est pas
majoritaire est-ce qu'on peut avoir le
texte de l'Assemblée soit il voulait
qu'il y ait pas de texte soit on veut
quand même que le gouvernement que la
France dispose des outils pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui mieux régler les problèmes
d'expulsion ou d'évacuation des gens qui
n'ont rien à faire notre pays c'est pas
la réal politique c'est c'est la
politique tout simplement qui répond aux
attentes des Français et merci merci
pour cette réaction en direct au micro
de public c'estci merci à tous les deux
merci Quentin encore une fois Pascal
Perino c'est c'est intéressant ce que
nous dit François patria il est en train
de nous dire là ça se joue à l'Élysée et
et attendons attendons le vote quoi
c'est-à-dire que peut-être que Emmanuel
Macron va remettre de la cohérence dans
dans le vote des députés hésitants et
oui le parti de la majorité
parlementaire du moins à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le parti du président et
comme toujours sous la 5e République
quand il y a conflit c'est le président
de la République qui tente de remettre
de l'ORD ord on verra s' est capable de
remettre de l'ordre ou si voilà il y a
quelques forces qui
résistent à l'appel à la discipline du
du président de la République et ce sera
quand même éclairant pour la suite du
quinena c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
passionnant de de voir ce qui se déroule
ce soir c'est ça qui est important parce
que s'il y avait j'allais dire beaucoup
de pertes en ligne c'est le scénario un
peu du Parti socialiste à la fin de la
présidence Hollande c'est-à-dire ça se
délite
voilà frondeur ce sont quelques unités
qu'est-ce que ça changera sit façon il
se représente pas donc non non non non
non bah si sur sa capacité à réformer
pendant 3 ans quand mêmeant avant la la
présidentielle à laquelle il ne se
représentera pas il y a tout même 3 ans
à tenenir donc c'est important pour pour
l'avenir surtout quand il dit voilà moi
pour l'instant je refuse la dissolution
et cetera donc il faut qu'il donne du
contenu avec une majorité qui tienne et
qui ne voilà ne se dissolve pas sous
l'impact des frondeurs on aura la
réponse très bientôt oui c'est pour ça
que cette soirée elle va être
passionnante puisque je vous rappelle on
est dans un quart d'heure le vote
commence au Sénat et à 21h30 à
l'Assemblée Émilie zapalski c'est je
voudrais qu'on se projette justement sur
cette capacité d'Emmanuel Macron à
continuer de de réformer et à
trouver une majorité je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer ce soir mais s'il perd
plusieurs dizaines de de députés sur ce
vote de la loi immigration c'est une
hypothèse pour àt-il les récupérer sur
d'autres textes voyez c'est ce qui est
en train de se jouer moi j'y crois pas
beaucoup alors je sais pas comment il va
rétablir la co
bohion mais je pense que les têtes vont
voilà vont redescendre mais c'est la
première fois j'ai l'impression qu' sont
assez qui sont allés aussi loin Sacha
aoulier on a entendu aussi des ministres
mettre dans la balance leur démission on
a vu dans dans un article du Figaro qui
avait eu des des rumeurs comme quoi
trois ministres notamment vouleit
démissionner si le texte allait jusque
là si ferme c'est la première fois
frisou rappelle l'une des infos cette
fins
ouaiisit n'accepa
pasexendé on sait pas ce que ça veut
dire mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est
une
voilàne de vote d'abstention à minima
quoi minima mais je pense que c'est
c'est un signe c'est un signe parce que
c'est la première fois en effet qu'il
sortent du bois autant que ce soit prier
ou deème quin ka en marquant ça moi a
priori et puis vu les efforts qu'ils ont
fait à mon avis Emmanuel Macron va les
ramener à la raison ce soir probablement
ouis la c'est un signal après c'est le
sens à donner de ce quinena qui n'a pas
de sens depuis le début ce deuxème
mandat réforme des retraites alors si il
a un sens c'est de plus en plus à droite
finalement réforme des retraites à 64
ans là l'immigration on voit que les
plus fortes réformes elles sont quand
même marquées à droite mais ce qu'on
voit surtout et c'est vrai que c'est la
majorité relative qui l'oblige c'est que
le sens du quinena c'est surtout faire
des compromis mais est-ce que tout
toutes les fins du compromis justifient
les ou à quel
pr qui Valiquer est-ce qu'il va faire un
petit coup àe avec je sais pas une
réforme
sur qu Mme l'ption dans la constitution
de l'intervtion volontaire de
grossess la dem sur non plus alors on a
entendu un représentant
de on a entendu représentant de
renaissance Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie
qui a participé d'ailleurs à cette
commission mixte paritaire sénatrice
socialiste de Paris est avec Quentin
Calmet exactement Thomas elle est bien
membre elle était membre de cette
commission mix paritaire réunie depuis
hier bonsoir madame de La gonrie on
apprend cette réunion de crise on peut
le dire entre le Président de la
République et plusieurs cadres de sa
majorité avec les ministres concernés
qu'est-ce ça vous évoque cette réunion
là qui vient de s'improviser à l'Élysée
bah je pense qu'il y a une comment dire
il y a un décrochage total entre la tête
de l'État et la base si on peut dire
notamment les députés c'est-à-dire que
ce qui s'est passé en commission mixte
paritaire n'a pas été une surprise le
texte nous ne nous convenait pas nous
avons
combattu donc comment se fait-il qu'il
n'y ait pas eu
anticipation bon donc effectivement le
il semble que le vote soit extrêmement
peu assuré ce qui est pas très étonnant
parce que ce texte ça a été dit
d'ailleurs en commission mixte paritaire
à la fin de la Commission son mix
paritaire les représentants du
rassemblement national ont félicité mais
j'utilise les mots ont félicité la
droite et les macroniste d'avoir d'être
venu sur leur thèse en entend sa
chaoulier qui annonce ce soir qu'il va
voter contre le texte sorti de la CMP il
l'a voté on est d'accord à la fin de la
CMP tel que vous y avez assisté est-ce
que vous l'avez entendu pendant ces de
jours dire que ce texte n'allait pas lui
lui convenir à la fin non mais bon il
présidait la CMP donc il n'avait pas à
s'exprimer particulièrement il y avait
les membres de son groupe il votait
quand même oui mais alors je vous cache
pas que j'ai pas passé mon temps à
surveiller son vote j'ai plutôt regardé
le vote du rassemblement national à la
ça vous évoque C ces figures de
renaissance qui annonce ce soir
notamment monsieur matthi pour le modem
qu'il vont voter contre mais encore une
fois on pense trop que quand on fait de
la politique on est totalement
déshumanisé qu'on a jamais de conviction
que tout est possible on sait bien
depuis un certain temps que ce texte
dérive on sait bien qu'il y a un
problème avec la thèse du rassemblement
national la préférence nationale on on a
écoutez j'ai dénoncé ici dans cet
hémicycle lors de l'explication de vote
sur le texte le fait que les digues
étaient rompu entre la droite française
et le Front national donc tout ça n'est
pas nouveau mais je pense que tout ça a
été sous-estimé et que au fond ces ces
députés n n'ont pas été suffisamment
respectés mais pour Emmanuel Macron et
c'est ma dernière question est-ce que
c'est un tournance ce qui se joue autour
de ce texte en terme de ligne politique
selon vous parce que vous parliez de
cette rupture de barrage entre LR et le
RN là ça va plus loin aujourd'hui oui
c'est-à-dire que on a assisté à la fin
du macronisme c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel
Macron voulait un texte coûte que coûte
y compris en étant sous la dicté de de
de des républicains y compris en allant
éventuellement sur les terres de
l'extrême droite donc il y a une il y a
une fracture sur la conception politique
que défendait Emmanuel Macron ensuite
oui je pense que ça va être un tournant
très rude chez les Français parce que
beaucoup vous savez on comment dire on
cru c'est pas péjoratif dans la bouche
on crut que Macron allait proposer autre
chose et puis allait il l'avait dit
faire barrage
entre contre contre le Front National et
là il s'allie avec eux bien merci merci
Marie-Pierre de la gontere sénatrice
socialiste de Paris vous étiez memre de
cette CMP merci pour cette réaction à
notre micro merci à tous les deux jouris
qu'on qu'on s'intéresse et qu'on rentre
un peu dans le détail de ce baromètre au
doxa mascaré pour Public Sénat et et la
presse quotidienne régionale avec
d'abord un premier élément qui concerne
Emmanuel Macron euh c'était avant même
évidemment les les événements de ces
dernières 48 heures on voyait déjà sa sa
code de popularité baissé à la question
el Macron est-il un bon Président de la
République non 66 % oui 33 % une baisse
de 2 points c'est son socle de gauche
qui se fragilisait déjà un petit peu et
qui continue de se fragiliser est-ce que
c'est ça l'analyse ou pas d'ailleurs non
non pas particulièrement parce qu'il a
baissé un peu chez chez LR aussi mais ça
reste tendantiel mais ce qu'il faut
noter pour Emmanuel Macron si on fait le
le bilan de son année 2023 c'est qu'il
avait déjà perdu des points fortement
avec la réforme des retraites sa côe de
popularité était légèrement remontée il
y avait son attitude qui avait été salué
face au conflit israélo-palestinien là
il reperd de points et au global sur
l'année 2023 il aura perdu 8 points il y
a un mois ce qu'on observait c'était un
fort risque de vote sanction aux
élections européennes c'est la première
fois que les Français retourneront aux
urnes après la séquence de la
présidentielle et des législatives là on
va même au-delà du vote sanction aux
élections européennes il y a un
sentiment d'ingouvernabilité qui a
commencé à se diffuser pas dit qu'il va
se qu'il va se solidifier mais il il y a
ce sentiment là et il y a le côté
réformiste d'Emmanuel Macron qui peut
peut-être être un peu affecté ce
réformisme un peu dynamique face au vent
contraire le décloisonnement
l'efficacité de la politique là c'est
peut-être que son image peut être sapé
sur ce côté-là et surtout auprès de son
socle électoral on l'a en signale faible
mais chez Élisabeth borne elle perd 10
points chez les sympathisants
Renaissance ce mois-ci mot rapide Pascal
Perino sur le rendez-vous que Emmanuel
Macron donne à rendez-vous avec la
nation en janvier qui de sortir du
chapeau le président
on verra il y a nécessité voyez on est
on est depuis des semaines j'allais dire
des mois on passe d'un événement à un
événements avec des jeux parlementaires
complexes et cetera il faut redonner un
peu de j'allais dire
d'espace alors l'espace vous nous le
donnerez un peu plus tard parce que j'en
donne à
Yan le sénateur écologiste pardon Pascal
qui est avec Quentin oui effectivement
Thomas je suis avec J bonjour monsieur
jado une réaction à ce qui se joue en ce
moment le sens surprise le Sénat qui
dans quelques minutes va adopter les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire ça sera plus compliqué à
l'Assemblée nationale et il y a une
réunion de crise à liser en ce moment
avec les cadres de la majorité les
ministres concerné qu'est-ce ça vous
évoque cette situation en ce moment une
faillite politique et morale pour le
président de la République il a voulu
faire de la tactique en mettant de côté
les valeurs de la République les valeurs
du camp qu'il est censé représenter les
valeurs de celles et ceux qui ont voté
pour lui deux fois en 2017 en 2022 pour
éviter Marine Le Pen vous savez j'ai
comparé cette situation au brexit
qu'avait lancé David Cameron à ce
point-là oui parce qu'il voulait faire
de la tactique en pensant qu'il jouait à
coup sûr mais à partir du moment où vous
créez un débat qui est fondé sur des
mensonges des contrevérités des
fantasmes sur l'immigration que la
société est aussi déstabilisé angoissé
et ben vous ouvrez la boîte du pire vous
ouvrez la boîte de la libération de la
parole et des actes raciste vous ouvrez
la boîte de la remise en cause des
valeurs de la République et on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il ne tient plus sa
majorité et on comprend pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire selon vous
retirer le texte depuis le début retirer
le texte on peut parfaitement par en
améliorant la circulaire Vals mieux
régulariser les personnes qui
travaillent et qui participent de notre
pays tout le monde convient qu'il faut
pas remettre en cause laame on va pas
remettre en cause le droit du sol c'est
ça que contient ce texte vous rendez
compte la
victoire culturel politique et à ce
rythme électoral de Marine Le Pen dans
lequel le président de la République
nous a engagé bien merci merci an jado
pour cette réaction en direct au micro
de Public Sénat merci Quentin on
approche de l'heure qui était prévue
mais je je vois les images de la séance
il y a encore discussion autour d'un
autre texte il aura sans doute une
suspension de séance avant que le vote
n'intervienne sur cette loi immigration
donc on a encore le temps d'analyser les
uns et les autres et Pascal je vous
redonne la parole sur la marge de
manœuvre d'un Emmanuel Macron qui a déjà
essayé d'inventer beaucoup de voilà on
va dire d'initiatives pour redonner du
souffle à à son
quinquena on voit mal annoncer la
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'il en ressortirait sans doute
pas une majorité plus plus solide et
encore personne sauf le r un intérêt à
une dissolution donc qu'est-ce qu'il
peut faire donc en effet il faut pas
rien voilà parce que il y a il y a 3 ans
qui un peu plus de 3 ans même qui qui
attendent le président et il va falloir
redonner un peu de souffle alors qu'il
n'arrive pas à trouver ce second souffle
depuis 2022 alors on peut imagin pourit
imaginer hein on pourra imaginer un
grand débat pasqueal Perino SP grand
débat grand grandbage je ne crois pas
cirque un grand déballage une
explication au yeux dans les yeux avec
les Français un M cou pas des politiques
non les les Français ils attendent à ce
que les hommes politiques et au premier
rang desquels le président fasse des
choses bon là on peut en discuter voilà
il y a cette loi immigration qui a été
voté il y a quelques mois c'était la loi
sur les retraites et cetera ça plî ou ça
déplait mais il y a des actes et
certains Français peuvent avoir
l'impression on verra que les choses
changent mais là c'est intéressant ça
malgré la difficulté il y a des réformes
s ça peut être mis à son crédit ça et ça
ça peut être mis à son crédit alors que
en face on a très souvent le ministère
de la parole et le ministère des
indignations hein là il y a des choses
qui sont faites alors on peut imaginer
que dans les mois qui viennent dans la
perspective du macronisme originel il
s'occupe un peu j'allais dire de sa
gauche alors il y a des dossiers en
effet comme le travail par exemple sur
lequel il pourrait trouver euh à
construire des majorités puisque c'est
le défi qui est le sien le défi de son
camp avec plutôt des forces de gauche
même si on le voit ce soir il a
fortement irrité les forces de gauche
mais les forces de gauche c'est normal
signe ce soir de de de de ce qui se
passe mais enfin il y a une semaine il
votaient aussi avec le rassemblement
national la motion de rejet et je me
souviens des images qui étaient
extrêmement frappantes où il y avait
toute la gauche nupesse qui
applaudissait avec qui avec le
rassemblement national cette victoire du
rejet de de de discuter le texte donc
vous voyez il y a beaucoup de posture he
faut bien reconnaître il y a beaucoup de
posturees et puis si vous me permettez
simplement 20 secondes il y a tout le
monde sent que le Front National est à
la hausse dans la perspective bien avant
ce ce ce projet de loi immigration
d'ailleurs il est à la hausse et
maintenant on voit très bien que
commence à savoir mais qui a fait monter
hein qui a fait monter le Front national
alors la gauche va dire c'est Macron
Macron va dire c'est la gauche ou
d'autres choses LR va dire bah voilà ce
sont les ambiguïés de Macron et c'est la
démagogie de la gauche voyez ça y est ça
a commencé ça a commencé de pour
préparer la soirée la soirée de des
européennes de joint
oùance de commenter la victoire du
rassemblement national on commentera
votre sondage un mot de la réaction à à
l'éisée la réaction du président de la
République laéticia cet après-midi il se
disait à l'Élisée que Emmanuel Macron
était agacé et voulait tourner la page
et voulait en finir rapidement donc on
imagine la tur deion ce soir on va voir
mais alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que est en train de se mettre en place
toute la rhtorique les éléments de
langage on appelle ça en communication
politique du président qui arrive à la
fin de son mandat puisque tout le monde
dit tout son ourage dit Emmanuel Macron
craint plus que tout de laisser le
pouvoir à l'extrême droite
quand on vous écoute ce soir on a
compris que c'est c'était le scénario
qui tenait l'ORD aujourd'hui donc en
gros il commence à préparer son terrain
pour sa postérité pour expliquer que ce
n'est pas de sa faute ouais avant avant
2027 il y a effectivement les
européennes le mois de
juinran donc vous avez interrogé les
Français sur leurs intentions de vote la
question c'était si les élections
européenne avait lieu dimanche prochain
pour laquelle des listes suivantes il y
aurait-il le plus de Chan que vous
votiez et là on voit on voit un RN très
haut absolument et al c'est vrai que ça
n'est le scénario que d'aujourd'hui ça
n'a pas valeur de pronostic pour les les
élection européenne mais ça montre un
rapport de force qui est très favorable
au rassemblement national et même plus
largement à l'extrême droite on a 31 %
des Français qui voteraient pour la
liste du rassemblement national contre
uniquement 21 % pour la liste de la
majorité présidentielle il y a 10 points
d'écart entre les deux mais il y en a
aussi 6 % qui voterait pour reconquête
la liste de Marion maréchal ça amènerait
à 37 % le total reconquête plus
rassemblement national et en tout 34
sièges au Parlement européen sur les 41
dont dispose la France la gauche on
aurait seulement 20 donc ça dit quand
même la droitisation et même l'extrême
droitisation si vous me permettez le mot
euh de du paysage politique sur cette
élection européenne c'est c'est un point
quand même à à à prendre en compte et
surtout cet écart de 10 points
impressionnant entre la majorité
présidentielle et le rassemblement
national qui passerait à 29 sièges il en
avait 23 en
2019 la majorité présidentielle
reculerait elle de de trois sièges avec
pourtant 2019 qui était déjà une
campagne européenne de Nathalie liseau
qui avait été vécu comme une
contreperformance par la majorité la
majorité est arrivé juste un point
derrière le RN mais avec un trend qui
lui a été très défavorable ils étaient
partis beaucoup plus haut dans les
sondages jusqu'à baisser et passer
derrière le RN qui lui a un peu monté
donc ils ont vraiment le le un dynamisme
une dynamique électorale autour Dee le
RN poussé par un double moteur à la fois
cette notabilisation dont on a parlé le
fait que des personnalités comme Marine
Le Pen Jordane Bardella Marion maréchal
s'instalent dans le paysage politique
deviennent fréquentable donc il y a il y
a cet effet notabilisation puis a
l'effet actualité avec le poids des
questions de sécurité et d'immigration
aussi aujourd'hui qui les place au cœur
du jeu politique mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que vraiment la dynamique
électorale est derrière eux ser ce sera
peut-être pas parine Le Pen en 2027
parce que tout le monde dit ce sera elle
ce sera elle moi je dis juste je suis
d'accord avec vous Émilie on a ouvert la
fenêre d'overton vous savez céit c'est
un symbole qui a été théorisé par le
juris du même nom Overton aux États-Unis
pour dire cette fenêtre d'overton
symbolise ce qui est possible et ce qui
est audible dans une société dans le
débat public là aujourd'hui elle s'est
complètement ouverte on entend des
choses acceptables qui ne l'étai pas il
y a même 5 ans notamment sur cette
thématique de l'immigration bien sû et
notamment avec la tournée médiatique de
on est là là ces derniers jours et ce
matin sur France Inter quand il dit je
suis prêt pour occuper Matignon la seule
les seuls arguments qu'on lui oppose sur
France interre c'est son âge trop jeune
passé d'expérience ça aurait été
impossible il y a quelques années on a
un ministre deéducation nationale qui a
33 ans donc c'est c'est possible he le
jeunisme non mais effectivement il y a
une acceptation on va dire de
l'hypothèse du rassemblement national au
pouvoir qui était qui était pas évidente
y a quel ne seraitce que quelques Ann
coup
ouise va arri à à la M
argent pe arriver c'est dans longtemps
et les européennes c'est dans 7 mois
donc là aussi il peut se passer pas mal
de choses mais quand même Ilie zapelski
je retiens votre argument sur le le le
contexte il y a il y a le socle et puis
il y a le il y a finalement ce que
l'actualité apporte ou peut apporter au
rassemblement national est-ce que
c'était un risque de faire voter un
texte immigration maintenant ou est-ce
que finalement euh c'était pas le seul
moment pour le faire parce que sinon
après on était encore plus près de de
l'échéance d'illeur l'avait l'avait un
peu accéléré avait accéléré son passage
au moment de du tragique événement à
haras parce que le contexte était plus
porteur en fait pour ça donc oui
forcément ça facilite et à mon avis il
va pas avoir beaucoup de choix que de
continuer un peu là-dedans justement
quand on voit les sondages que vous que
vous donnez là sur les élections
européennes que de dire en gros bah je
suis obligé de montrer mes muscles du
côté de ces sujetsl
H qui va
Mo ilemu Macron il est quand même il a
essayé tous les trucs et on en a parlé
le grand débat les rencontres de de
Saint-Denis il a essayé le Conseil
nationalondation référendum oui le
référendum peut-être que c'est ça et il
serait
urgent il serait urgent en effet de
réouvrir un peu sur son en même temps si
c'est toujours un en même temps
équilibré ou alors c'est vraiment un
coming out sur un en même temps qui est
clairement à droite c'est ça c'est soit
il fait le choix de dire bah c'est bon
je suis parti beaucoup plus à droite que
je ne l'étais en 2017 soit il
rééquilibre sur des sujets et il y en a
pas mal et surtout s'il revenait sur les
sujets en plus il est assez bon
d'économie de réindustriisation
peut-être même c'est un gros mot mais
d'aménagement du territoire he c'était
le sujet des gilets jaunes c'est-à-dire
métropole contre territoires ruraux péri
urbain il y a un vrai sujet en France
là-dessus parce que sur ces sujets-là
même si le rassemblement national est
très bon etess parler à l'oreille des
les territoires ruraux notamment qui
avant votaient plutôt Parti communiste
ou Parti socialiste et ben souvent quand
on les interroge là-dessus ils sont
beaucoup moins bons pendant que vous
nous parlez on voit le ministre de
l'Intérieur pardon qui est en train de
de de d'arriver dans dans dans
l'hémicycle ici au Sénat il y a une
courte interruption de séance et donc on
devrait avoir le vote sur cette
immigration dans quelques an c'est
peut-être là où il pourrait montrer les
muscles ok sur les sujets de sécurité
immigration il durcit le tempon est-ce
qu'il peut pas durcir le ton justement
c'est ce sujet de pouvoir d'achat
d'économie de réindustrialisation et
autre gros mot sur les écologie aussi he
parce que le rassemblement national et
l'écologie on est quand même très loin
donc il il y a beaucoup d'endroits où le
potentiel du rassemblement national
n'est pas très bon ça ça effectivement
ça ouvre je trouve c'est vraiment très
intéressant ce que vous nous dites sur
la la marge on y revient la marge de
manœuvre Pascal Perino d'Emmanuel Macron
mais alors pas seulement là début
janvier quand il va prendre la parole
sur les textes qu'il peut proposer les
réforme qu'il peut impulser pour
éventuellementer le rassemblement
national alors je crois vous allez pas
pouvoir répondre à la question parce que
désolé Quentin vous reprenez la
main et voilà le premier vice-président
LR qui préside la séance merci à tous
bonne soirée